paul balboa go ahead hey now how you
doing would you ever have fred on as
your guest to do a full
interview like he was a true guest on
your show i think i kind of did that
once with fred i think i had a long
conversation with fred once on the air
i remember that day you think it was a
long interview but i timed it it was 92
seconds
you want to know something early on
radio i learned a couple of things
fred is good in small doses but that's
why i would like to hear
a long interview with a friend well
she just wants to see you suffer howard
you want to know something and robin
won't admit this robin once
uh said to me in private and i hope you
don't mind me revealing this she's i
know she turned to me
she said howard 92 seconds with fred is
a lifetime
anything that takes away from robin time
is just
oh now you got him turning on me i never
remember
robin once said on your side fred i'll
never get those 92 seconds back
it's gone here i'll try one question
with fred
and we'll see how it goes all right
let's see
yep so fred what'd you do over the
vacation
oh no you see
[Laughter]
fred seriously how was your vacation
fred here we go
it was fine there you go all right
thanks fred that was awesome
wasn't that great if people on the
academy award should have learned from
fred
what the [ __ ] imagine an hour of that i
love
fred i've been working with fred the
longest out of anybody on this show
and even with all of the love in my
studio i built a wall specifically not
to see fred
an actual wall there it goes no more
fred
i blocked him
all right fred is now hidden from my
view and the audience's view
and i doubt i'll ever take that screen
down only up
i think you started covered so you
didn't have to see me
i did i invented it by the way
paul bobo i straightened out my little
studio down here sometimes things get
messy that's what i did during my
vacation
i rode my motorcycle i cooked some
dinners
and that's it where did you expect i'm
gonna do a follow-up like barbara
walters
where did you ride your motorcycle i
went to
montauk point it's very beautiful there
you went somewhere to just
look sometimes i just like to ride just
to clear my head
clear your head you say to clear my
clear my head yes
right right so you rogers you can't
clear your head
in any other way okay all right here's
the interview paul boba wanted and i'm
giving it to him
now this is what is in your head you're
not getting cleared
get out after a while it starts to get
on your nerves that you're like you're
in a house you just got to get out you
got to feel
sort of free and it's a safe way to do
it so you didn't really clear your head
you just wanted to get out of the house
you do clear your head
by getting out and seeing and not only
is is much different riding
on a motorcycle than it is driving in a
car you get
what is it about your family that you
have to get out of the house from them
what went wrong
i get on their nerves and they get
online sometimes you know
you got on your wife's nerves over the
vacation i get on her nerves you
actually forget interviewing fred
longform let's interview fred's wife
long form
i want to see how when he what irritates
her
oh my god fred's out of the house thank
god
i'm sure she does so fred when you got
to montauk point
yeah i'm being serious because i don't
get this
you got there you get off your bike do
you park the bike or you sit on the bike
and look at montauk point
i got off the bike and i looked because
it's a really beautiful view it's almost
like a
it's not a 360 but you get to see long
island sound all the way out you know
how long do you spend looking at long
island sound i probably spent 10 minutes
looking
you stared for 10 minutes the stairs i
stare
i stare for 10 minutes yes why 10
minutes can't you get
one or two minutes and then kind of
watching your clock
i mean are there new things that you
pick up during minutes seven
eight nine that you couldn't have picked
up in minutes this is the beauty of the
universe
i'm not putting you down i'm just trying
to understand in other words oh no you
are putting me down but that's okay
yeah i feel you need to
so you spend ten minutes looking i think
you'd be done in five minutes looking at
montauk
and then you turn around and go but it's
more the ten minutes is to kind of
reconnect your thoughts as well
because when you're riding you're doing
nothing but thinking about riding the
motorcycle itself
he gets on the motorcycle to clear his
mind
right yes then he gets to montauk point
to reconnect his mind
all right paul bubba there's the big
interview with fred uh we heard about uh
fascinating uh we got a window into
fred's world
he wrote his motorcycle i did listen i
love you
i adore you you are a genius and i do
not want anything as are you on that
motivation
[Laughter]
i spoke to robin over the weekend i
can't believe what a genius she is
and if you don't know she'll tell you oh
she told me all right
i don't even i i don't even know what to
say there you go and what you don't know
she knows all right and fred thank you
for the interview i'm sure all that
thank you my friend
all right we'll talk again in five years
thank you
completely now